[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like hey guys in this video I'm bringing
the alleged leaked outline for season 8
premiere I will share the outline for
episode 1 of the final season that was
sent to me and I will provide you some
evidence to support many of these events
actually happening during season 8 but I
cannot and will not claim it being real
in the past I've shared outlines that
turned out to be kind of percent
accurate but I also shared some that
turn out to be fake you never know which
outline is real and which is fake what I
can do however share good ones and let
you decide whether it's real or not in
any case you'll find out in April 2019
when the first episode of the last six
airs it is being said if you don't mind
potentially getting spoiled let's get
right into it the alleged outline for
the very first episode of the season
claims that season 8 premiere opens up
and Winterfell with the arrival of Jon
Snow Daenerys Targaryen and their crews
and armies legit or not season 8 is
confirmed to open up in Winterfell
Entertainment Weekly has been providing
the first exclusive look at what's to
come in next season of Game of Thrones
ever since it started and this year was
no different they shared some legit
spoilers for the final season which
besides battle for Winterfell and many
more other teases also included a
detailed description of the opening
scene the final season is confirmed to
open am interval the opening single city
arrival of John and Danny with a
gruesome interval which is said to be
similar to King Robert's arrival in a
series premiere it is spoiled that this
episode will be an episode full of
minions so if you've been waiting for
Jon to reunite with Arya or for area to
reunite with the Hound or for almost the
entire game internal screw to be
together at the same place good news is
we'll finally get it in the very episode
of the final season beside many reunions
premiere will also feature many tense
first meetings between characters since
I said not to be thrilled that jam-band
and into his fancy new Targaryen
girlfriend at least on the first which
is also stated later in this outline
back to it it says sense a Brandon Arya
Stark much of the known lords and Lords
of the Vale lined up to greet Queen
Danian Jon Snow Prince stark saw them
coming I'm sorry but I gotta stop right
there isn't it interesting how the
Starks lined up to greet their new queen
just like they lined up in the very
first episode to greet King Robert also
an interesting thing is brain seeing
them arrive before everyone else just
like he didn't already mention first
episode of the series back then brain
climbed on the rooftops of the castle
and saw the royal party come into view
he told this matter hokodan climbing
that the king is here in Winterfell did
less preparations for royal okay
now seven season scepter brand season
alert Sutter's so Queen Danny and
gemstones arrival at Winterfell although
it's two different types of site that
alert his brain of King Robert and Queen
Danny's arrival it's nonetheless an
interesting parallel
okay back to the outline he continues
the dragon's fire but Winterfell stark
siblings three night with Jon Snow since
a stark is not happy with Danny there's
a lot of John my Winterfell or he
understands the situation many Iranians
too many to count
Janan goes reunite later in the episode
again better this outline Israel or not
all these remains and tensions have been
confirmed to happen anyways after
initial greetings John has been told
about the fall of the wall and the fall
of lost heart mine end of the episode
the night King attack scar hold to
ampersand Karstarks are gone let me stop
right there to remind you that brain to
his flock of Raymond's witness the night
king is throwing a large portion of the
wall using the onion bazarian allowing
his armies to march south and therefore
it only makes sense for him to share
this major information with Jon Snow and
he most likely did shared that his
sister's two before John even arrived
regarding the fall of lost heart and car
whole there's nothing to say but it's
been expected the seat of how somber is
the northern most major castle of the
Seven Kingdoms it has an it will fall
first in the eastern half of the north
south of the Bay of seals last car hold
the seat of house car Sark located
southeast of the previous castle that
was hit but nonetheless is the second or
most castle so with their deaths at the
end of season 7 most fans assume the
next battle we see will be am interval
but there's a lot of castles between
Winterfell and wall the night king will
need a few episodes throw right there
but make no mistake he will arrive and
it will be the biggest battle sequence
in all the history of TV in general
anyways his the fall of these two
castles been expected yes has it been
foreshadowed yes in the season 7
premiere Jon Snow warned the north Lords
that if the wall shall fall the seats of
house number and Karstark are likely to
get hit first with their castles being
the most distance norm settlements once
again real or fake this outline is not
wrong about it another major event it's
definitely going down maybe not exactly
as it says but it most certainly is
happening outline continues to the
Greyjoy's
it says team grey jury tries to savior
Greyjoy he arrives at Pike but Yara is
not there nor is urine outline is not
making mistake here as well early on in
the season we will surely see if you're
attempting to save Yara and his first
attempt will also surely fail see indeed
learn from you
that his sister is alive and he plans to
kill her soon if he doesn't submit
himself to him Thea knows earn the
respect of the arm born fee indeed
really then to rescue her and his
journey on his way to our Islands to do
so but he doesn't know what he will find
there which is nothing journey sailing
his arm fleet with us to bring the
golden company to his queen and he most
certainly did not leave her behind the
scene switches to your own bringing in
screen what his promised the ganga
company it's as young graduate as a
designer flee to the capital with the
golden company twenty thousand infantry
and cavalry accompanied by the war
elephants led by a new character you're
on sir seeing the leader of the gun
company a character named here we
discussed the war plans and strategy
carrie Strickland says the sir says
something along the line I proposed to
take storms and first an impregnable
stronghold once taken it will give us
the secure fastness to which we may
retreat at need and winning it will
prove our strength again there's no
doubt of urine arriving with the golden
company this new character the leader of
the gun company has also been confirmed
to appear in the final season the next
event in the South line is about the met
Queen sibling Jaime
it says Jim Lee nice Tyrell is the
Riverlands this is something I
personally expected and I actually
talked a lot about in my season 8
prediction videos I did not expect Jaime
to show up at Winterfell gates
empty-handed
especially so in small part to the lanes
two armies located in the Riverlands
basically instead of traveling his
entire journey in the Kings Road that
runs from the capital straight towards
Winterfell Jaime will travel on it only
to the crossroads n the crossroads Jim
will take the river road that runs west
into the Riverlands
he will go forever and rarely the
Lannister forces that were sent to the
Riverlands to ensure peace along the way
he might even come inside near tally
with whom he has quite a bad history to
rally all of the Riverlands and marched
them to Winterfell
and help his nieces and nephews defeated
threat they're all facing after all it
says jamie rellis the Riverlands not a
small amount of Lannister soldiers
brain is a vision of the Mad King
burning his grandfather and killing his
uncle that's very interesting but also
expected because such flashback was
already supposed to take place in the
very first season that scene was even in
the season 1 trailer
outline continues with huge meeting in
the Great Hall of Winterfell John Tenney
Tyrion and other lords discuss how to
defend the north during Asher's Danian
channel serves his intentions shield
Moorish her armies nor no doubt censor
disagrees John commands all the northern
Lords the exception of Howland Reed to
March their men
in children food and supplies to
Winterfell general comments Lord read to
stay the greywater watch John explained
something along the line I've sent word
to Holland read fighters old friend and
greywater watch if the White Walkers
come down the neck the chronic man will
bleed them every step of the way they
will buy us enough time to form a new
line of defense if needed be in the
books Rob says something very similar to
this line to his matter kept the Ovenden
staid the unsullied are sent to the
dreadfort this makes sense as the
dreadfort is north of interval and
therefore the castle the night king will
hit first
it's also been foreshadowed by sense
that the north will use most of their
castles in the Great War not only Minter
fell in the season 7 premiere census
said we need every fortress we have for
the war to come
following the battle the bastards house
Bolton has become extinct leaving the
dreadfort without any ruling lordship
however House Stark only captured
Winterfell from the Bolton's no mention
is made the dreadfort being captured so
it's possible they are still a Bolton
garrison holding the castle these very
few men will apparently be aided by the
unsullied who has this outlined claims
were sent over there to fight the night
king whether its audience solid or just
part of them remains unknown this part
is also supported by the official tease
for season 8 in which the unsullied
marker isn't assigned a stark marker an
interval but somewhere east of it which
could be the dreadfort the attendance
state Cersei has a miscarriage
this is something that was already
supposed to happen in a season 7 finale
but the showrunner decided to rather
have it in season 8 premiere anyways it
continues by claiming that John and
Danny agreed upon keeping the
relationship in secret fear spreads
across north many are leaving for the
south in the winter town people spread
rumors of the nat king flying on a
dragon and White Walkers riding their
pale giant spiders big as hounds
I got a stop right there to once again
say that even if this South line turns
out to be fake similar scenes to those
have been confirmed to happen in the
winter town it was confirmed in January
when all the famous news sites covered
exclusive news of season 8 premiere
since being filmed in the winter town
the winter town for those who don't know
is a settlement located just outside of
Winterfell itself during the winter
months the population can swell as sky
it's 15,000 full of old men women and
children making a decease target right
by Winterfell for the netbeans army to
take and sell their ranks if you
remember is the place very first
material and it snuck off from
stuffiness so being a guest of the
Starks I had a little fun with Ross we
also spent some Long John
since dari Brianna she waited for Sansa
to give her signal it's also going to be
interesting to see these rumors among
small folk about the I spiders are going
to turn out to be more than just a rumor
throughout the show many characters
mention them and with the night king
starting his conquest it would be time
for them to finally appear I spiders are
legendary creatures spoken of his some
accounts and tells about why workers
they are supposedly the size of hounds
and sometimes ridden by White Walkers in
season one Alden recounts to brain stark
legends about when the White Walkers
first descended upon Westeros during a
long nine thousands of years ago raising
the dead is why it's to kill the living
riding the horses and hunting with packs
of giant eye spiders as big as hounds
the attendant says the Lord said marches
the Nights Watch south of the wall with
them tormented beric Dondarrion
Tyrion Lannister writes a letter sends
it in secret passing by the moat Cailin
older man with a short beard writes
North Way through 8,000 men he wears
green clothes and wields a three-pronged
spear in a letter shield does this
description remind of someone green
collar or a spear is it Howland Reed is
he writing known to me interval even
though Justin commanded him to stay away
water watch and why to tell Jon Snow the
truth
maybe this marks the end of episode 1
this leaked outline of the season 8
premiere does seem interesting and if
true we can expect quite a long episode
with all these events that have been
mentioned let me know what you think
about this alleged leaked outline in the
comment section down below and as always
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and they hope to see you in
the next one peace
[Music]